und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend sachsen anhalt hat gewählt
und die steine wie der cdu in magdeburg
und berlin vom herzen fielen konnte man
landauf landab laut plumpsen hören mehr
noch seit langem mal wieder richtig
fröhliche gesichter bei der union mit
einem so guten ergebnis hatten sie
selbst nicht gerechnet
auch das von manchen prognostizierte
kopf an kopf rennen mit der afg blieb
letztlich aus der abstand zu dem zweiten
platz ist deutlich schauen wir uns also
die zahlen die neuesten andy hat
matthias wolf ja guten abend aus
magdeburg hier ist die neuste
hochrechnung
demnach bekommt die cdu in
sachsen-anhalt 36,6 prozent der stimmen
und gewinnt sehr deutlich dazu hier
unten sehen sie gewinne und verluste im
vergleich zur wahl 2016 die afg 21,8 die
linke käme auf 10,9 prozent die spd
einstellig 8,2 prozent die grünen 5,7
prozent auch deutlich weniger als
erwartet die fdp 6,5 prozent nach 10
jahren wieder im landtag in magdeburg
vertreten und für die freien wähler hat
es nicht gereicht 3,1 prozent was heißt
das für die sitzverteilung im parlament
hier in magdeburg 83 sitze gibt es
mindestens es wird aber weil die cdu
mehr direktmandate gewonnen hat als ihr
nach zweitstimmen zustünden
überhangmandate geben und
ausgleichsmandaten für die anderen
parteien
am kräfteverhältnis änderte das nichts
deshalb können wir mit diesen 83 rechnen
die cdu käme auf 34 die fdp auf 20 sitze
linke zehn spd 8 grüne 5 und fdp 6 die
absolute mehrheit die liegt dann bei 42
sitzen und jetzt schauen wir mal für
welche koalitionen das reichen würde
42 sitze ist die linie die man erreichen
muss kenia das amtierende bündnis von
cdu spd und grüne
kommt locker drüber 47 sitze wenn die
fdp mit im boot wäre statt den grünen
wären es sogar 48 sitze die sogenannte
deutschland koalition und jamaica cdu
grüne fdp hätte 45 sitze auch das würde
reichen
cdu und spd und das ist das erste mal an
diesem wahlabend kämen auf 42 sitze
genau das was man mindestens braucht es
ist eine hauchdünne mehrheit die die
hätten
und das ist noch zu früh um zu sagen ob
das wirklich so zustande kommen wird das
wird erst das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis zeigen ob es dafür reicht
irgendwann rund um mitternacht so viel
für den moment danke matthias ja wie
gesagt spannend wird jetzt die frage
welche regierung reiner haseloff daraus
dann tatsächlich ein dreierbündnis wird
es vermutlich seien so viel lässt sich
wohl vorher sagen aber er kann dafür
sowohl in kenia bleiben als auch nach
jamaica ziehen oder zu einer schwarz rot
gelben deutschland koalition oder wir
haben es eben gehört vielleicht ginge
auch ein bildnis allein mit der spd in
seiner partei finden jedenfalls viele
ist am attraktivsten die grünen gegen
die fdp auszutauschen
abgesehen davon gibt es in der sachsen
anhalt cdu ja auch durchaus stimmen die
sich im gegensatz zu ihren
ministerpräsidenten eine koalition mit
der fdp hätten vorstellen können wenn es
gewusst hätte
so erklären sich vielleicht auch cdu
wahlkampfslogans die vor allem vom
kommunismus warnten als seien die linken
die hauptkonkurrenten
darüber habe ich mit reiner haseloff vor
der sendung gesprochen doch erstmal fast
an der typische zusammen wie der tag in
magdeburg verlief luftanhalten bei der
cdu kurz vor 18 uhr dann der befreiende
jubel über den sieg vor allem aber über
den deutlichen vorsprung vor der afd
der zuletzt alles andere als sicher galt
reiner haseloff punktet mit seinem
amtsbonus und will nun zum dritten mal
regierungschef werden da ich bin
überglücklich und ich freue mich über
dieses vertrauen und ich verspreche den
menschen dass ich das auch wirklich
erfüllen werde
was sie von mir erwarten tiefes
durchatmen also bei der cdu gequältes
lächeln bei der alv
angetreten stärkste kraft im parlament
zu werden landet sie derzeit bei fast 23
prozent leicht unter ihren historischen
einzug ins parlament vor fünf jahren
spitzenkandidat oliver kirchner der vor
allem mit widerstand gegen die korona
maßnahmen punkten wollte gibt sich
dennoch zufrieden ich bin überhaupt
nicht enttäuscht ich bin froh darüber
wir sind volkspartei im osten andere
sind es nicht mehr hier muss die wähler
der linken zurück geholt die arbeiter
das wollten wir schaffen und deswegen
bin ich sehr zufrieden
die linke zwar drittstärkste kraft aber
mit weniger als elf prozent fährt sie
ihr bisher schlechtestes ergebnis in
sachsen-anhalt ein
es ist eine herbe niederlage für uns
hier als linke in sachsen-anhalt und ich
muss feststellen dass es uns nicht
gelungen ist auch mit einem starken
wahlkampf mit wichtigen themen wie der
ost west gerechtigkeit mit
gesundheitswesen diesen bundestrend in
dem wir uns gerade bewegen diesen zu
durchbrechen
ein ähnliches bild bei der spd nachdem
sie schon 2016 ihre wählerstimmen
halbierte rutscht sie nun deutlich unter
die zehn prozent marke
ich weiß dass viele wählerinnen und
wähler überlegt haben wenn sie denn
tatsächlich wählen können um die afg als
stärkste kraft im land zu verhindern
deshalb finde ich es demokratisch
betrachtet gut dass die stimmen bei der
cdu gelandet sind für meine partei ist
es aber sehr sehr bedauerlich
lange gesichter bei den grünen 2016 als
puffer gegen rechts in deutschland
zuerst das klima bündnis mit cdu und spd
gestartet machten sie sich hoffnung
erstmals zweistellig zu werden und
pendeln sich nun bei nicht mal sechs
prozent ein
wir sind in einem ostdeutschen
bundesland das ist traditionell nicht
einfach für die grünen wir hätten uns
natürlich gewünscht dass wir noch
deutlich mehr zu stimmenzugewinne haben
um den klimaschutz auch in einer
nächsten regierung deutlich stärker
vorantreiben zu können
die fdp der zweite große gewinner des
tages zum ersten mal nach zehn jahren
zieht sie wieder in den landtag ein
[Applaus]
wir haben das zusammen geschafft wir
sind wieder eine fraktion im landtag von
sachsen anhalt sechs parteien nun also
im nächsten parlament mit mehreren
koalitionsoptionen kenia deutschland
oder jamaika nun hat reiner haseloff die
geheilt hat weiter
bevor wir darüber gleich mit ihm
sprechen schauen wir uns nochmal die
hauptkonkurrenten an der cdu die knapp
22 prozent der afc in sachsen anhalt
zeigen schon auch welches potenzial die
partei im osten hat sie zeigen aber
vielleicht auch auf wo die grenze liegt
insbesondere für einen landesverband der
so radikal ist dass er vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird
im wahlkampf gab es auch noch dazu
passende enthüllungen etwa dass zwei
fraktionsmitarbeiter führende kader der
inzwischen verbotenen neonazistischen
gruppe heimattreue deutsche jugend waren
deren abkürzung hdj nicht zufällig so
klingt wie sie klingt rund 22 prozent
der wähler in sachsen-anhalt finden
diese völkischen nationalistische bis
rechtsextremer ausrichtung entweder gut
oder nehmen sie in kauf
aber dazu gewinnen konnte die partei
trotz der korona krise auch nicht
daniela sonntag berichtet extra
angereist zur wahlparty nach
sachsen-anhalt alexander gauland und
böcke wollten groß feiern
doch dann stutzen das ergebnis zwar
knapp gehalten aber nicht stärkste kraft
nicht zugelegt
wir haben aber auch keine wählerstimmen
verloren das heißt wir haben diejenigen
die uns 2016 gewählt haben nicht
enttäuscht und da auf mich stolz
die jagdsaison ist noch lange nicht
beendet die jagd geht weiter
den corona frust der menschen in
wahlerfolge ummünzen
der plan ist nicht ganz aufgegangen oft
ohne masken und ohne abstand als einzige
hatte die afg größere wahlkampfauftritte
auf den marktplätzen balsam für die
eigene klientel beschimpfungen für
gegner die affen die zu unserer musik
packe viel gebrüll von rechtsaußen ein
landesverband der nach medienberichten
vom sachsen-anhaltischen
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird und
ein spitzenkandidat der das für
irrelevant hält sich mit der stasi große
worden dieser verfassung ist das für
mich kein maßstab und doch wieder über
20 prozent wieder im osten warum es ist
aber so dass die der rechtsaußen kurs
der afg im osten offenbar weniger
abschreckende wirkung entfaltet als im
westen wo man sich die jüngsten
landtagswahlen anschaut diesmal hat das
mobilisierende thema gefehlt und es ist
der afg eben nicht für sie in
ausreichendem maße geglückt an die krone
einer demonstration anzudocken
platz zwei nicht mehr die allermeisten
wähler in sachsen-anhalt sind darüber
heute erleichtert im anbetracht dessen
dass afg dann doch auch nur auf dem
zweiten platz ist finde ich das schon
gut weil die auf die örtliche her
finde ich gut schweiz eine bessere
perspektive fürs land ist heute abend
haben zwar andere gewonnen aber die afg
bleibt stark in sachsen-anhalt reiner
haseloff was uns aus magdeburg
zugeschaltet guten abend herr haseloff
gut so ein deutliches ergebnis da können
sie sich zu recht natürlich heute abend
sehr freuen aber sie wird mir über tag
fast selbst ein bisschen überrascht das
ist dann so klar und deutlich war aber
das muss ich klar zu geben und das ist
auch eine riesenfreude heute die ich
jetzt habe
auf der anderen seite haben wir hart
gekämpft und ich glaube dass wir auch
jährige strategie hatten auf die
wählerinnen und wähler so zu gehen dass
sie wirklich merken worauf es jetzt
ankommt das ist unser match geht das ist
um unsere zukunft geht und die kann nur
mit einer klaren abgrenzung nach rechts
laufen und deswegen muss man die mitte
stärken
das ist interessant dass über strategie
strategie sprechen beschuldigung
natürlich ganz klar heute abend auch
eine massive amtsbonus das ist schon
auch ihr wahlsieg aber eine strategie
braucht natürlich trotzdem und gab es
auch aber die war so ein bisschen
doppelt einerseits zu sagen ganz klare
abgrenzung nach rechts aber andererseits
wissen sie besser als ich gibt es in
ihrer partei einige die haben da auch
andere töne gespielt richtung afd
entgegenkommen werden sie da künftig
jetzt noch klarer in ihrem kurs werden
können jetzt mit diesem ergebnis im
rücken was sie meinen das sind ganz klar
einzelne personen und die haben spielt
in der partei keine rolle wird der
beschlusslage noch in der politik und
der politischen ausrichtung jedoch kann
sich auf mich verlassen wenn es darum
geht diesen abgrenzungskurs hoch zu
halten und die kinder koalition war ja
auch ein ergebnis dass wir demokraten in
der mitte wussten wofür wir in der
verantwortung stehenden sachsen anhalt
und das ist auch so eine stabile
regierung in der mitte geben müssen da
gibt es kein wenn und aber
naja 100 personen das sind jetzt schon
nicht nur einzelne und auch nicht nur
hinterbänkler sondern die sitzen auch
auf dem vorderen landeslisten plätzen
wie es jetzt zu dieser wahl auch gab
ja das mag sein dass sie dort personen
finden die sich sozusagen zu
klassifizieren
ich weiß nur dass diese person ganz klar
mich auch mit dominiert haben dass diese
personen auch klar konsequenzen gezogen
haben und auch sehen dass wir damit auch
den richtigen kurs hatten und dass da
mit meiner person auf verbunden bleibt
egal wie die diskussionen bei anderes
laufen diese partei hat mit 95 prozent
nominiert und ich habe immer klar gesagt
mit reiner haseloff stehen folgende
kriterien fest und diese sind nicht nur
in der partei bestätigt worden
mit großer großer mehrheit sondern eben
auch vom volk da wäre die wählerinnen
und wähler haben heute entsprechend
entschieden und damit ist auch für die
zukunft das klar was für mich und für
meine politik auch in der vergangenheit
klar würden sie dann beim nächsten
wahlkampf nicht mehr wahlkampf machen
mit kein bock auf kommunismus sondern
vielleicht kein bock auf rechtsradikale
zumindest haben wir keinen wahlkampf
gemacht die wessis müssen geachtet
werden sonst wird es ihnen ja
möglicherweise schlecht gehen in mainz
da sind wir wie gesagt als partei der
deutschen einheit ganz anderes unterwegs
und den kommunismus wollen wir nicht
kommunismus ist ja nur ein synonym dafür
dass wir auch mit den linken keine
koalition machen wollen
und das steht in unserem parteiprogramm
drin denn sie wissen die link name ihrem
programm drin zu stehen dass sie dieses
system abschaffen wollen wir denken sie
jetzt auch nicht die große macht in
magdeburg aber da sie das stichwort
koalition gerade noch gaben viele in
ihrer partei würden sehr gerne die
grünen gegen die fdp austauschen
haben sie für diese wünsche ein
besonders sympathisierende sohr wir
haben den letzten 20 jahren verschiedene
koalition gehabt und deswegen können wir
alle partner auch die handelnden
personen und es wird jetzt wirklich ganz
sachlich und fachlich ausgelotet mit wem
man am meisten auch von seinem eigenen
programm entsprechend des wählervotum es
auch umsetzen kann und das wird wirklich
ganz offen ergebnisoffen also verhandelt
erst mal sondiert und dann
es wird ja parallel eine
geschäftsführende landesregierung
weiterhin geben wir haben wir in
koalitionsverhandlungen eintreten und
eine regierung der mitte bilden und das
muss man dann sehen was dann auch über
die parteigremien jeweiligen partner
entsprechend entschieden wird
danke für das gespräch bitteschön für
die größe nach mainz nach den
erkenntnissen der forschungsgruppe
wahlen glauben die wähler in
sachsen-anhalt mehrheitlich nicht dass
kanzlerkandidat laschet große
auswirkungen auf das wahlergebnis hatte
und sie meinen auch dass die wahl in
sachsen anhalt noch lange nichts über
den ausgang der bundestagswahl
vorhersagt in der tat sachsen anhalt ist
nicht repräsentativ für
gesamtdeutschland aber den ein oder
anderen finger zeit gibt es aus
magdeburg trotzdem etwa das wie immer
viel von den jeweiligen kandidaten
abhängt und dass sich die grünen ihrer
umfrage erfolge nicht sicher sein können
und die spd sich wirklich sorgen machen
muss dazu gleich noch ein gespräch mit
saskia esken die im politischen berlin
auf die heutigen ergebnisse reagiert
wurde berichtet jetzt patricia
wiedemeier
die erleichterung ist groß die botschaft
klar wenn die union geschlossen auftritt
können wahlen gewonnen werden so die
ersten reaktionen aus dem adenauer-haus
der kurs sich von der afg abzugrenzen
habe sich gelohnt
die menschen haben gesehen die cdu steht
für einen vernünftigen kurs der mitte
für sozialen ausgleich und hat einen
starken ministerpräsidenten und genauso
werden wir es auch im
bundestagswahlkampf handhaben mit armin
laschet an der spitze und einer
geschlossenen cdu
die botschaft ist klar und eindeutig die
cdu kann noch wahlen gewinnen und das
ist eine eindrucksvolle bestätigung auch
für unseren kanzlerkandidaten armin
laschet insofern eine gute ausgangslage
für die bundestagswahl trotz aller
freude auch der cdu müsste zu denken
geben dass die afg zweitstärkste partei
geworden ist bei wahlen im osten
scheinen die internen querelen der
letzten zeit nicht abzuschrecken
es gibt ganz normal überall regionale
unterschiede das ist doch bei jeder
anderen partei genauso wie die die cdu
hat in den städten zum beispiel auch
ganz andere ergebnisse als auf dem land
wir haben im osten starker ergebnisse
die spd verschwindet in ostdeutschland
insgesamt ist politik in ausdauerlauf
und wir werden auch im westen zu länger
bei mir ziemlich sicher und das ist für
uns motivation auch für die
bundestagswahl
enttäuschend dagegen die ergebnisse
sowohl für spd linke und grüne sie alle
eint die erklärung sie hätten stimmen
durch die polarisierung zwischen cdu und
fdp verloren
diese polarisierung die auch ein stück
weit inszeniert worden dass haseloff
oder afd
wo wir jetzt sehen dass der 14 prozent
dazwischen liegen jetzt natürlich dazu
geführt dass viele gesagt haben so
schlecht soll mein land dann doch nicht
da stehen dann will ich sie die
landtagswahlen sind immer sehr
landesspezifisch das haben wir auch in
allen vorangegangenen landtagswahlen
gesehen deswegen die bundestagswahl
da geht es um was anderes da geht es um
eine erneuerung unseres landes nach der
pandemie
aber klar ist wir haben uns in sachsen
anhalt ein bisschen mehr erwünscht es
ist eine wahl die jetzt nicht zu sagen
hat für das was 112 tagen ist die
bundestagswahl
also da kämpfen wir da sind wir
geschlossen da gibt es viele
möglichkeiten auch noch über themen zu
reden und wir haben mit olaf scholz das
zeigen die aktuellen befragung wir haben
den kanzlerkandidaten denen die menschen
sich am besten im kanzleramt vorstellen
können nach zehn jahren schafft die fdp
den wiedereinzug in den landtag sieht
sich nun natürlich im aufwind für uns im
bund
bestätigt sich unser kurs sehr seriös
aber auch kritisch mit der politik der
großen koalition umzugehen
die fragen der bürgerlichen
freiheitsrechte nach vorne zu rücken
ganz offensichtlich haben unsere
antworten für die wirtschaftliche
belebung für die modernisierung unserer
wirtschaft viele menschen dort überzeugt
die reaktionen im politischen berlin
zwischen aufatmen und alarmstimmung die
große erschütterung ist ausgeblieben
aber mit blick auf die bundestagswahl
haben vor allem linke und spd wenig
grund für optimismus und das berliner
sonst die spd vorsitzende das essen
zugeschaltet guten abend fresken guten
ist das ein bitterer tag ist das wurde
heute schon mehrfach von spd kämpfen
gesagt 8 prozent und 8 prozent noch
weniger als beim letzten mal wenn es ein
bundespolitischen effekt gab dann bei
der auf jeden fall negativ oder also ich
werde ganz deutlich sagen das ist
natürlich ein ergebnis ist uns nicht
zufriedenstellen kann und dennoch habe
ich nicht nur ich sondern auch norbert
walter wo ja ins auch olaf scholz auch
lars klingbeil sachsen anhalt in den
letzten tagen besucht und wir haben sehr
sehr engagiert kämpfende mit ganzem
herzen kämpfen der sozialdemokratinnen
und sozialdemokraten gesehen
allen voran katja pauly unsere
spitzenkandidatin die haben themen
gesetzt die wirklich auch belangen haben
für das leben der menschen in sachsen
anhalt und das ist stark über
überblendet werden natürlich zu den
zunächst und corona und dann aber auch
wie schon mehrfach gesagt von der
polarisierung jetzt in richtung afd und
das ergebnis ist wie es ist
wir werden jetzt in den nächsten wochen
und monaten deutlich zu machen haben
dass es um wirklich wichtige themen geht
die wir in zukunft auch zu gestalten
haben und dass die spd ist mit seiner
polarisierung hätte ja auch der spd
nutzen können es hätten sich auch wähler
sagen können in solchen zeiten wichtig
dass man die sozialdemokratie wieder
stärkt das ist hat nicht stattgefunden
im gegenteil es sind fehler so fd
gelaufen hfg sagt nicht ohne unrecht 29
prozent der arbeiter wären es 10 afd in
sachsen anhalt das doch erschüttern für
eine sozialdemokratische partei
wir müssen schon in den nächsten wochen
und monaten deutlich machen was wir auch
in den letzten wochen versucht haben das
denn dann wesentlich höherer mindestlohn
das
in ost und west angeglichen löhne
angeglichen renten auch das ist ein
wichtiges ziel ist um eben den menschen
in ost und west auch deutlich zu machen
wir gehören zusammen
glauben sie dass es allein diese
ökonomischen gründe sind dass es
wirklich lohn fragen sind die einen dann
dazu bewegen sein kreuz dort oder dort
zu machen
ich glaube dass es lohn fragen sind dass
es verteilungsfragen sind und dass es
auch fragen der der gerechten
infrastruktur sind wie beispielsweise
gut ausgestattete schulen und wohnungen
und ein gut ausgestattetes an den
menschen orientiertes gesundheitssystem
das für gerechtigkeit sorgt und die
menschen dürften nach gerechtigkeit das
können wir immer wieder hören fragen der
sozialen gerechtigkeit spielen eine
große rolle ja gerade einem land wie
sachsen anhalt das ja auch wirklich
einen strukturwandel noch hakt da gibt
es noch kohlekumpel wie einst im
ruhrgebiet die um ihren job bangen aber
die wellen nicht spd wir werden in den
nächsten wochen und monaten deutlich zu
machen haben dass wir gemeinsam mit olaf
scholz auf die richtigen auf die
richtigen themen sitzen dann dass wir
die richtigen konzepte haben da geht es
eben genau um die gestaltung dieser
umbrüche dass auch mitnehmen der umbruch
erfahrung der menschen im osten
deutschlands
um eben den digitalen wandel und auch
den klimawandel die bewältigung des
klimawandels gemeinsam zustimmen
klar sind dass die themen mit denen sie
da aber nicht so wirklich ankommen und
durchdringen ich glaube dass wir
deutlich machen müssen dass wir die
situation die unterschiedliche situation
auch in den in den verschiedenen
bundesländern zwischen stadt und land
der menschen vor augen haben und dass
wir bereit sind diesen weg mit ihnen
gemeinsam zu gehen vor allem auch
sicherheit zu geben
soziale sicherheit zu geben aber auch
die sicherheit teilhaben zu können
weiterhin auch durch ein recht auf
weiterbildung beispielsweise auch im
beruf fit zu bleiben und dabei zu
bleiben
sie sagten gerade und walter bauer
walter borjans und olaf scholz waren
auch noch mal zu besuch in sachsen
anhalt aber das scheint nicht viel
gezündet zu haben
dieses trio ist jetzt schon so dass wir
auch in sachsen anhalt ein hoher
briefwahl anteil gewesen ist das heißt
die letzten tage die wir jetzt dort
unterwegs waren konnten auch in dem maße
natürlich nicht mehr finden das ist ja
eher eine unterstützung für die dortige
landespartei als dass man sagen würde
die brauchen uns um ein gutes ergebnis
einzufahren
da macht man noch mal gut die termine um
auch denen die wahrnehmung zu
verschaffen aber tatsächlich haben wir
nicht das ergebnis erzielt das wir
erzielen will
es ist ein ergebnis da sind sie
eigentlich im bereich der kleinen
parteien und nicht mal erreichte der
volkspartei ich habe es unumwunden
gesagt es ist ein ergebnis das uns nicht
zufriedenstellen können wir haben viel
zu arbeiten den nächsten wochen monaten
und wir sind aber auch genau darauf gut
vorbereitet
das wird man sehen fresken danken für
das gespräch
da gehen und zur wahl in sachsen anhalt
jetzt noch ein kommentar von
chefredakteur des zdf peter frey reiner
haseloff hat es geschafft der amtsbonus
stärkte den einzigen bundesweit
bekannten politiker sachsen anhalts
durch seine widerrede gegen merkels
corona politik konnte er bei den
eigenwilligen sachsen anhaltern
punktesammeln seinen klaren sieg gegen
die afd verdankt er auch der
polarisierung wer einen erfolg der
rechtsradikalen verhindern wollte der
welte haseloff unbestritten profitiert
der cdu bundesvorsitzende laschet von
haseloff sieg die kanzlerkandidatur wird
ihm nun niemand mehr streitig machen
ernüchternd ist das ergebnis für die spd
einstellig trostlos auch für olaf scholz
der als kanzlerkandidat hier im land
durchaus gefällt die grünen können bei
weitem nicht holen das erste umfragen
versprachen kein bernburg aufschwung in
sicht der osten bleibt die große
baustelle
der klima partei die liberalen ziehen
zwar wieder in den landtag
ob sie mitregieren entscheidet jetzt
haseloff im koalitionspoker hat er die
qual der wahl
die linken stürzen tief auch deshalb
kann die afd
ihr ergebnis vom letzten mal fast halten
trotz fortschreitender radikalisierung
eine machtoption haben die
rechtspopulisten nicht aber mehr als 20%
afd wähler
es bleibt ein alarmsignal für unsere
demokratie sicher gerade in sachsen
anhalt wo björn hatte heute zur afd
wahlparty kam gibt es eingefleischte
rechtsextreme es gibt aber auch das
gefühl nicht wahrgenommen zu werden oder
benachteiligt zu sein wenn die neue
regierung soziale fragen niedrige löhne
eine schlechte infrastruktur energisch
anpackt dann können die wählerinnen und
wähler zurückgewonnen werden
die christdemokraten konnten heute ihre
macht also ausbauen haben die afg aber
nicht nachhaltig geschwächt von
demokratischer normalität ist sachsen
anhalt immer noch weit entfernt
dazu braucht es nicht nur die
verweigerung von zusammenarbeit sondern
ein selbstbewusstes gegenangebot wieder
frei kommentierte und jetzt macht hans
wolff weiter mit den nachrichten
gesundheitsminister sparen hat den
vorwurf um angeblich minderwertige
corona schutzmasken zurückgewiesen die
masken seien intensiv geprüft worden und
hätten alle nötigen eigenschaften
spd und opposition hatten ihm
vorgeworfen er habe unbrauchbare masten
an bedürftige verteilen wollen
spd chef walter borjans kritisierte
schwans krisen management und legte dem
koalitionspartner indirekt die
entlassung des ministers nahe
und der blick auf die korona lage und
die zahlen vom robert-koch-institut das
rk ii meldet 2440 neuinfektionen binnen
24 stunden das sind 1412 weniger als
vergangenen sonntag 74 todesfälle kamen
innerhalb eines tages hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sinkt auf 24,7 ab morgen fällt in
deutschland die priorisierung bei den
corona impfungen weg sie sind dann nicht
mehr vor allem älteren menschen mit
vorerkrankungen oder bestimmten berufen
vorbehalten sondern generell für die
impfwilligen freigegeben
allerdings soll es den sommer über
dauern bis für alle genug impfstoff da
ist
in mexiko findet die größte abstimmung
in der geschichte des landes statt mehr
als 20.000 enter werden neu besetzt
darunter parlamentssitze und
bürgermeister endter mehr als 90
millionen mexikaner sind zur stimmabgabe
berechtigt wie der wahlkampf war geprägt
von zahlreichen gewalttaten mindestens
90 politiker wurden seit september
ermordet dahinter werden rivalisierende
drogenkartelle vermutet unwetter mit
teils heftigem starkregen haben in
vielen regionen deutschlands punktuell
große schäden angerichtet wie hier in
sachsen kam es zu überschwemmungen
nördlich mussten unter hüllte oder unter
schlamm begraben der straßen gesperrt
werden
die feuerwehr war im dauereinsatz zum
beispiel um keller auszupumpen
vielerorts ereigneten sich unfälle die
meisten verliefen glimpflich
zum sport kanada bis zum 27 mal
eishockey-weltmeister beim turnier im
lettischen riga besiegte das team im
finale titelverteidiger finnland mit 3 2
nach verlängerung
die deutsche mannschaft hat ihre
hoffnung auf eine medaille bei der wm in
riga nicht erfüllen können
im spiel um platz drei gab es eine 1
6-niederlage gegen das us team im
zehnten turnierspiel will deutschland
einfach nichts glücken setzt bei
überzahl geht der puck ins tor
die usa dagegen stecken den frust über
ihr verlorenes halbfinale locker weg
drei tore gut vier minuten die mit
abstand höchste deutsche niederlage bei
dieser wm
nach den großartigen leistungen der
vortage scheint das team von toni sailer
rollen auch mental restlos erschöpft im
häf'n dominik bittner crypt noch zum 1
5-endstand aber sechs zu eins
für die usa die fußballerinnen von
bayern münchen haben sich die vierte
meisterschaft der vereinsgeschichte
gesichert mit einem 4 0 gegen eintracht
frankfurt am letzten spieltag der
frauen-bundesliga den formel 1 grand
prix von also bei zahnhals sergio perez
geworden vor sebastian vettel und
paisley der wm gesamtführende max
verstappen schied nach einem unfall aus
nach vier tage sind heute die finale zu
ende gegangen einen der deutschen
meistertitel an diesem schlusstag
gewarnt weitsprung weltmeisterin war
leica hamburg in braunschweig mit einer
weite von 6 metern 62
den titel im turm synchronspringen
holten in berlin patrick hausding und
timo bathe hausding hatte gestern
bereits im kunstspringen vom drei meter
brett gewonnen und dann fort zu guter
letzt jetzt noch der blick auf die
nächste woche christian von rechenberg
hat da einige wichtige termine
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
wer ist verantwortlich für den abschuss
des fluges ma 17 richterinnen und
richter aus den niederlanden die das zu
entscheiden haben sahen sich vor wenigen
tagen das rekonstruierte wrack genau an
überzeugten sich unter anderem von
spuren einer flugabwehrrakete am
dienstag beginnt nach langer
vorbereitung nun das hauptverfahren
es geht um mord an 298 menschen
angeklagt sind vier männer drei russen
und ein ukrainer alle auf der flucht
start der berlinale teil 2 die meisten
filme im wettbewerb hatten jury und
fachleute ja schon begutachtet online
oder in kleiner runde
nun darf das publikum gucken und zwar
achtung im kino aber nicht in diesen
hier nein mehr so draußen
es ist sommer da geht open air und für
so was hat berlin ja platz 16 orte
zweieinhalb wochen lang summer special
er liegt schon etwas zurück der letzte g
7 gipfel nach einem jahr zwangspause
trifft man sich am freitag nun wieder in
cornwall gastgeber boris johnson muss
dicke brocken auf tischen corona handel
klima
immerhin kein störenfried mehr in sicht
das könnte ein produktiver gipfel werden
der erste für joe biden der letzte für
angela merkel
ebenfalls am freitag der parteitag der
grünen in berlin wieder digital sowie
der letzte aber auch ebenso geräuschlos
das spitzenduo hat fehler gemacht die
delegierten werden fragen stellen wollen
und diskutieren auch über das
wahlprogramm mehr als 3000
änderungsanträge liegen vor härtetest
für die gern betonte geschlossenheit und
zu den wetteraussichten zum start in die
neue woche im emsland an der ostsee und
an der oder scheint morgen die sonne
sonst gibt es schauer südlich des mains
auch gewitter örtlich mit starkregen die
temperatur erreicht 17 bis 24 im
nordosten 28 grad schauer und gewitter
gibt es auch in den nächsten tagen am
donnerstag nur noch im südosten in
norddeutschland scheint die sonne am
längsten die höchsttemperaturen liegen
zwischen 19 und 28 grad
ich sag mal nicht das was von uns es
folgt der sonntagskrimi 0 30 gibt es
dann die nächste heute express und hier
erwarten sie morgen claus kleber und
gundula gause die sie durch die nächste
woche wieder sinn
[Musik]